con un fuerte apretón de manos así
recibió el presidente manuel macro al
príncipe heredero de arabia saudita
mohamed ben salman en el atrio del
palacio del elíseo en una polémica
visita que rápidamente desde la
presidencia francesa aclararon es una
visita oficial y no de estado y una cena
de trabajo los partidos de oposición
tanto de la izquierda como de la extrema
derecha criticaron esta visita pues
recordemos que mohamed benassal man es
el principal sospechoso por el asesinato
de periodistas saudita disidente llama
al show cuyo cuerpo fue encontrado en el
año 2018 en la sede del consulado
saudita en estambul
solamente el partido de derecha de los
republicanos no criticó esta visita dijo
que era necesaria en un contexto de
crisis
energética sobre todo cuando arabia
saudita es el principal exportador de
crudo bruto del mundo sin embargo
dijeron que el tema de los derechos
humanos no podía estar ausente de esta
escena para responder a las críticas el
palacio del elíseo dijo que se va a
hablar de los derechos humanos de este
encuentro aunque no se dieron más
detalles pero también de otros temas es
como la guerra en yemen donde arabia
saudita combate a los rebeldes hutíes o
el acuerdo nuclear con irán cuyo no
cumplimiento preocupa a arabia saudita
el principal rival de la república
islámica en medio oriente también de la
situación económica en el líbano gran
aliado de francia y también de la crisis
energética aunque dijo francia no se
espera ninguna decisión de arabia
saudita pues un aumento eventual de la
producción petrolera por parte del rey
no tiene que ser decidida en el seno de
la opep